hey everyone this is going to be a brief
tutorial on how to measure your download
and upload speed it's a very simple
tutorial first thing you want to do is
open any web browser you like preferably
your fastest browser to get the most
accurate reading and I'll show you
exactly into the URL bar www.speedtv.com
bytes 512 kilobytes so I'm going to pick
the server closest to me within the New
York the New York River and here's also
a pretty cool number of the original
number of tests that have taken place so
here's a left test of my internet speed
it says testing download first and it's
going to test the upload speed now this
is nowhere near my fastest speed I'm
running several things in the background
here but I will actually be able to show
you my fastest speed when this is done
so also testing upload and it's down to
0% and it is done so now this will this
screen will fade out and it'll give you
a number of options this is all in built
into your browser you can rate your
internet service provider I'll give it a
four stars and I'm gonna go down here it
also tells you the distance from the
provider I am less than 50 miles from
the server that I tell you with and it
will give you several options you can
test again you can put a free speed test
by embedding it on your own site you can
see people's statistic for the
statistics for the entire world and you
can compare your results with others
which is what I'm going to click on and
you can see my my pestis test here I got
about eighty six megabytes per second
download speed my fastest up I'm gonna
say was this one where I got about 2.3
megabytes per se so yeah 86 Meg's a
second is a really sweet download speed
that was when I was just getting to
using my new computer and I also tested
my download speed in Calvary
which is about 25,000 miles from where I
am and I about a mega second
I mean I'm I have a really good internet
service provider so if you want to test
go ahead and post your results in the
comments to whatever like that is how I
test my internet downloads and upload
speed so if you've if you've had a bad
day maybe with your internet connection
and you test it and says it's fine and
everything it's an it's not actually a
tweet a quick neat little way to
diagnose problems as well and I'll show
you in a later video how to diagnose
some networking problems so if you like
this video go ahead and subscribe next
one please